how do we begin
to fix social media would you say okay
so here's the most important thing to
understand
in the social sciences
you know we say is social media harmful
to kids that's a broad question you
can't answer that directly you have to
have much more specific questions you
have to operationalize it and have a
theory of how it's harming kids and so
almost all of the research is done on
what's called the dose response model
that is
everybody including the researchers are
thinking about this like let's they
treated this like sugar um you know
because the data usually shows a little
bit of social media uses and correlated
with harm but a lot is so you know think
of it like sugar and if kids have a lot
of sugar then it's bad so how much is
okay
but social media is not like sugar at
all it's not a dose response thing it's
a complete rewiring of childhood
so
we evolved as a species in which kids
play in mixed age groups they learn the
skills of adulthood they're always
playing and working and learning and
doing errands that's normal childhood
that's how you develop your brain that's
he become a mature adult until the 1990s
in the 1990s we dropped all that we said
it's too dangerous if we let you outside
you'll be kidnapped so we completely we
began rewiring childhood in the 90s
before social media
and that's a big part of the story um
i'm a big fan of leonardo skinnezy who
wrote the book free range kids if there
are any parents listening to this please
buy lenora's book free range kids and
then go to letgrow.org it's a non-profit
that lenore and i started with peter
gray and
daniel shukman
to help change the laws and the norms
around letting kids out to play they
need free play so that's the the big
picture they need free play uh and we
started stopping that in the 90s that we
reduced it and then
gen z kids born in 1996 they're the
first people in history to get on social
media before puberty
millennials didn't get it until they
were in college but gen z they get it
because you can lie you just lie about
your age um they so they really could
begin to get on around 2009 2010 and
boom two years later they're depressed
it's not because they ate too much sugar
necessarily it's because
even normal social interactions that
kids had in the early 2000s largely well
they decline because now everything's
through the phone
and that's what i'm trying to get across
that it's not just a dose response thing
it's imagine
imagine one middle school where everyone
has an instagram account and it's
constant drama everyone's constantly
checking and posting and worrying and
imagine going through puberty that way
versus imagine there was a policy no
phones in school you have to check them
in a locker no one can have an instagram
account all the parents are on board
parents only let their kids have
instagram because the kid says everyone
else has it we're and that's we're stuck
in a social dilemma we're stuck in a
trap so
what's the solution keep kids off until
they're done with puberty there's a new
study actually by amy orban and andy
schabilski showing that the damage is
greatest
for girls between 11 and 13. so there is
no way to make it safe for pre-teens or
even 13 14 year olds we've gotta kids
should simply not be allowed on
these business models
where you're the product they should not
be allowed until you're 16 we need to
raise the agent and force it that's the
biggest thing so i think that's a really
powerful solution but
it's a
it makes me wonder if there's other
solutions
like
controlling the virality of bullying
sort of if there's a way that's more
productive to childhood
to use social media so of course one
thing is putting your phone down
but first of all from the perspective of
social media companies it might be
difficult to convince them to do so
and also
for me
as an adult who grew up without social
media
it's so
social media is a source of joy so i
wonder
if it's possible to design the
mechanisms
both the
challenge the ad driven model but
actually just technically the
recommender system
um and how
viral
how virality works on these platforms if
it's possible to design a platform that
leads to growth anti-fragility but does
not lead to depression yeah uh self-harm
and suicide that like finding that
balance and making that is the objective
function not
not engagement yeah or i don't think i
don't think that can be done for kids so
i am very reluctant to tell adults what
to do i have a lot of libertarian
friends and i would lose their
friendship if i started saying oh it's
bad for adults and we should stop adults
from using it yeah but by the same token
i'm very reluctant to have facebook and
instagram tell my kids what to do
without me even knowing or without me
having any ability to control it
as a parent it's very hard to stop your
kid i have stopped my kids from getting
on instagram
and that's caused some difficulties but
but they also have thanked me because
they see that it's stupid they see that
what the kids are really on it
what they post they see that the culture
of it is is stupid as they say so
um i don't think there's a way to make
it healthy for kids i think there's one
thing which is healthy for kids which is
free play we already robbed them of most
of it in the 90s
the more time they spend on their
devices the less they have free play
video games is a kind of play i'm not
saying that these things are all bad um
but you know 12 hours of video game play
means you don't get any physical play um
so and ultimately physical play is the
way
uh to
to develop
physical and fragility and especially
social skills kids need huge amounts of
conflict with no adult to meet to
supervise or mediate and that's what we
rob them up so anyway that we should
move on because i you know i get really
into the evidence here because i think
the story is actually quite clear now
there was a lot of ambiguity there are
conflicting studies but when you look at
it all together
the correlational studies are pretty
clear and the effect sizes are coming in
around 0.1 to 0.15 whether you call that
a correlation coefficient or a beta it's
all in the standardized base it's all in
that sort of range
there's also experimental evidence we
collect true experiments with random
assignment and they mostly show an
effect
and there's um eyewitness testimony um
you know
with the kids themselves you talk to
girls and you pull them do you think
overall instagram is good for your
mental health or bad for you you're not
going to find a group saying oh it's
wonderful oh yeah yeah mark you're right
it's mostly good no the girls themselves
say this is the major reason and i've
got studies in the google doc where
they've been surveys what do you think
is causing the is causing depression
anxiety and the number one thing they
say is social media so there's multiple
strands of evidence do you think the
recommendation is as a parent
that teens should not use instagram yes
twitter yes that's ultimately maybe in
the long term there's no way there's no
way to make it safe there it's unsafe at
any speed
i mean it might be very difficult to
make it safe and in the short term while
we don't know how to make it safe put
down the phone well now hold on a second
play with other kids
via a platform like roblox or
multiplayer video games that's great i
have no beef with that
you focused on bullying before that's
one of five or seven different avenues
of harm the main one i think which does
in the girls
is not being bullied
it's living a life where you're thinking
all the time about posting
because once a girl starts posting so
it's bad enough that they're scrolling
through and this is everyone comments on
this you're scrolling through and
everyone's life looks better than yours
because it's fake and all that you see
are the ones the algorithm picked that
were the night anyway so the scrolling i
think is bad for the girls but i'm
beginning to see i can't prove this but
i'm beginning to see from talking to
girls from seeing how it's used is once
you start posting
that takes over your mind and now you're
basically you're no longer present um
because even if you're only spending
five or six hours a day on instagram
you're always thinking about it and when
you're in class you're thinking about
who how are people responding to the
post that i made between period you know
between classes um i mean i do it you
know i try to stay off twitter for a
while but now i've got this big article
i'm i'm tweeting about it and i can't
help it like i check you know 20 times a
day i'll check like what are people
saying what are people saying this is
terrible and i'm a you know 58 year old
man imagine being a 12 year old girl
going through puberty you're
self-conscious about how you look and i
see some young women i see some
professional young women women in their
20s and 30s who are putting up sexy
photos of themselves like and this is so
sad so sad don't be doing this yeah see
i the the thing where i disagree a
little bit
is i agree with you in in the short term
but in the long term i feel it's the
responsibility of social media
not in some kind of ethical way not just
in an ethical way but it'll actually be
good for the product for the company
to maximize the long-term happiness and
well-being of the person
so not just engagement so consider but
the person is not the customer so the
thing is not to make them happy it's to
keep them on
that's the way it is currently right
that driven if we can get a business
model as you're saying i'd be all for it
and and i think that's the way to make
much more money so like a subscription
model where
the money comes from paying it's
it's not
that would work wouldn't it that would
help so subscription definitely would
help but i'm not sure it's so much i
mean a lot of people say it's about the
source of money but i just think it's
about the fundamental
mission of the product
if you want people to really love a
thing i think that thing
should uh
maximize your long-term well-being
in theory in morality land it should i
don't think it's just this is land i
think in business land too but that's
maybe a discussion for another day we're
we're studying the reality of the way
things currently are
and uh they are as they are as the
studies are highlighting
you